c'est l'endroit le plus protégé au monde
périmètre de sécurité -policiers
services secrets et puis bien sûr prise
de température et test de dépistage
quotidien de coronavirus
alors lorsque l'ennemi public numéro un
pénètre sans vergogne dans cette
forteresse supposé impénétrables le
malaise s'installe conseiller de dans
notre chambre
là vous il a aujourd'hui peur d'aller
travailler à la maison blanche et se
sentiraient suis en sécurité chez lui et
ce qui est particulièrement gênant c'est
que c'est au coeur même de la cellule de
crise sur la coved 19 que le coronavirus
a frappé infectant l'attaché 13-10
président mike pence
le patron de la cellule de crise par
précaution les trois membres les plus en
vue de ce groupe
le docteur anthony fao çi en tête se
sont tous placés dans une forme d'auto
isolement le vice-président lui
continuera à travailler et sans masque
comme si de rien n'était même chose pour
dans le temple qui a minimisé en
conférence de presse l'importance de
cette contamination au sein même de la
maison blanche cela peut arriver dit il
après tout c'est un ennemi invisible se
disant convaincu que tous ceux affectés
vaut mieux s'en sortir
le président voulait surtout vanté les
récentes avancées en matière de tests de
dépistage 300 milles par jour
assure-t-il
plus que n'importe où ailleurs dans le
monde
des tests déployés à la maison blanche
mais qui n'ont pas empêché la
propagation du virus
protégeons la maison blanche qui est
très ironique
selon ce professeur alors que donald
trump s'évertue à convaincre les
américains que tout est normal qu'il est
temps de retourner au travail
autre signe que tout ne va pas si bien à
la maison blanche
une note interne vient d'être remise à
tout le personnel les masques ils seront
désormais obligatoire ici jean françois
bélanger radio canada